you
[Music]
all right it's it's my great pleasure to
have Jeff Walker here professor at UCSD
I think everyone knows who he is he he
has a he's done an immense amount of
impactful work in in the area of
security very recently he was awarded
the test of time award at USENIX
security and also last year he became an
ACM fellow jeff has had a long history
with us at Microsoft he's a friend of
ours he was the first intern in the
Systems Group here at MSR since then he
has had a lot of interaction with us
both directly and also indirectly with
his through his students who have come
and spend a lot of time with us and jeff
has also spent almost an entire year in
MSR India and so it's it's a great
pleasure to have our friend here thank
you thank you very much
Thank You chef all right is that are you
guys hearing through the mic great ah
it's fantastic to be here it's always
fun to come back at MSR you know I have
many many great memories you know going
all the way back to when I was an intern
when everything was just getting started
here and even when I was a super green
professor I'm just starting out UCSD
Victor helped me out a lot with both
support and advice and mentorship so you
know I have a very close and personal
history with Microsoft what I want to do
today is talk about some relatively
recent work that we've been doing in
sort of this cybercrime space we call it
evidence-based security and we have this
we call the center because the NSF style
funding that it is but essentially a a
large grant from NSF to do cybercrime
related research and this is something
that we also work very closely with Vern
Paxson at Berkeley going all the way
back to Whalen in previous projects and
you know the the style of security work
that that we wound up doing over time
sort of evolved in
to this style we're roughly speaking we
do a tremendous amount of measurement to
be able to understand the problem
the attackers what they're doing how
they're impacting users or
infrastructure or whatever it is they're
doing and then when thinking about how
to both understand and potentially
undermine and deal with some style of
abuse or large-scale attack to also not
just think about technical approaches
but also sort of the economics and and
social aspects of the attack as well as
additional leverage for trying to impact
what's going on and then finally to to
engage with attackers where possible and
so you know sort of in the set of work
that we've done the stuff that's
probably most well-known that we've
given lot to talk about is all the spam
work where are we you know going after
email spam and eventually search spam
and we bought a lot of drugs for science
and all this crazy stuff but in reality
actually we've done lots of different
things over time many many different
kinds of cyber crime related work I had
the stuff that I highlighted in blue are
actually projects that we work together
with with Microsoft we have a number of
projects that we've done with Saikat and
in particular but also the digital crime
unit when we were doing all of that then
email spam and stuff like that so it's
been great working with with Microsoft
one on these style of projects as well
so for today I wanted to cover sort of
two two relatively recent projects
they're not necessarily tied together
directly except that they're relatively
recent one is on something that we call
tripwire which is sort of a mechanism
for being able to infer site compromise
externally as a third party and then the
second is an effort looking at you know
the main motivation is to sort of
foundations for looking at abuse related
to DNS but starting out by exploring
what has happened with the introduction
of all of these new top-level domains in
in DNS and if there's additional time
probably not because I stalk a lot of
slides in here I can talk about sort of
where we're going from here
and at any point you know please feel
free to stop me if you have questions
it's much more fun for me if it's a sort
of interactive style talk okay
so I'll start with the first project
which was led by our student Joao de
Blasio this we have this system called
tripwire for being able to infer site
compromise and you know data breaches
and slight compromises are all over the
news you know lots of everybody has been
compromised and I can absolutely
guarantee you that UCSD has been
compromised many times over and you know
one question is sort of you know how
many compromises are there out there and
what is the rate who's being compromised
potentially why all these interesting
questions the challenge is trying to
measure this stuff externally because
nobody wants to admit the different
compromised it's sort of to me it's
analogous to we did the very early work
back in 2001 looking at denial of
service attacks nobody wants to admit
they're being attacked but can you come
up with ways to and for this externally
and so the idea that we had was that we
can get insight into compromises at
sites through the fact that people reuse
their passwords okay so you know general
the idea is that you know for any
arbitrary site out there let's say it's
even some hobby site users will sign up
the site will ask the users for their
email address and then a password and
that may be the credentials that they'll
use the login to the site and the reason
why attackers might break into a site
compromised it and then use the email
account and the password why it might
have value to them is because if there
is password reuse then they can go and
try to log in to the email account of
that user yes so they just breached some
other site over there which then led
some leapfrog into the webmail account
and then they have all of these sort of
assets associated with that email
account that they can mine and try to
monetize so there's actually a lot of
value and so when there are site
compromises and data
particularly of the credentials
attackers will routinely just take all
of the the email accounts that they find
and the passwords and just try to see if
they can log in to the email account and
if so they will use it directly or
resell those email accounts in bulk to
other attackers there's a lot of value
in attackers being able to do this ok so
then this sort of suggests a technique
for being able to detect site
compromised externally so what I'll do
is talk about sort of the the
methodology that we used and then a
study that we did over the span of about
a year and a half talk about the the
compromises that we detected and then we
did an additional step where we
contacted all the sites where we
detected compromised and sort of
interacting with them about what it is
they found and it was actually pretty
eye-opening that that disclosure step
wasn't quite sure what was going to
happen when I created exactly great ok
so with this the idea is is actually
very straightforward we're just gonna
partner with a large webmail provider
who asked to remain anonymous and we're
going to create a whole bunch of honey
email accounts and the we're gonna use
those email accounts one-to-one with
sites out on the internet and then we'll
just wait let's wait wait wait
eventually an attacker will compromise
one of these sites we don't know which
one is gonna wait and then they'll try
to login to our an account at the email
provider and then the email provider is
gonna be monitoring all these accounts
and will notify us if there any login
attempts whether they're successful or
not and then potentially even monitor
the activity of what happens to those
accounts when somebody loves it ok
that's the general idea
praise report specially easy or
something to ensure that a great
question and I'll give you $5.00 okay so
we when when you registered accounts of
the sites we actually registered two
accounts one account that had a easy to
guess password and another account that
had a heart attack password
and then when we looked to see if there
were login attempts to our accounts we
looked to see whether or not the
attackers were able to get into the EZ
account and get into the Hart account
and if they were able to get into the
heart account then that means that site
did not do a good job of securing
passwords they either in the clear or
very easily reverse-engineered using
rainbow tables or any you know standard
method out there so just that it lets us
differentiate and get some insight into
sort of the security privacy of the site
great question exactly doing this for
one or two sites very straightforward so
one of the technical challenges was
scaling this up so that we could just go
down lots of different sites and try to
register accounts with that and so a lot
of the work that Joe had to do was sort
of building an automated crawler to be
able to identify an account registration
page parse everything and then sign up
for the account get the email message to
confirm the registration click on that
and all that kind of stuff you know that
the actual the pages tend to be written
in such a way to make it hard to
automate that because in a way you know
large scale account signup is not
necessarily something that we want to
encourage or make it easy and then we
also supplemented the automated crawler
which is going down that the sites of
the otama Alexa and just doing manual
registrations if the crawler failed and
then at the the webmail provider we
generated the profiles for all of the
accounts the passwords and the account
usernames and then we would just give
that information to the web mom later
and then they would just create accounts
for us in bulk the webmail provider did
not know which accounts we had used and
or even which sites those those accounts
were associated with and what was nice
about that is that in the end we had
about a hundred thousand of these
honeypot accounts that we didn't sign up
anywhere and they were never accessed
which gave us a pretty good indication
that the webmail provider was not
breached so
having our accounts logged into was not
a result of the webmail provider itself
actually getting breached okay so then
we have this prolly we just go down the
Alexa rankings trying to identify site
so we can register at for the the sites
that actually had you know registration
pages we succeeded but the automated
crawler succeeded reasonably well but it
was focused on English sites that are
actually a lot of non-english sites in
the in the top Alexa and then some sites
that were very difficult to do and just
using an automated crawler you succeeded
about twenty percent of the time when
you failed
was it Credit Karma they scored a credit
card he was all sorts of different
things so they might ask for a credit
card it might be an ad very advanced
CAPTCHA where so to solve CAPTCHAs we
would just Analyst's the CAPTCHA solving
service and pay them and some of those
just couldn't handle the the interface
of using the service couldn't handle the
the advanced CAPTCHAs sometimes sites
will ask for one bit of information on
one page make you click go to another
page and during the next bit of
information and so on and so forth and
so this multi-step there are sites out
there so for example you know let's say
for you know power utility sites like
there's an account there but the only
way in which you can get it actually
login and register is if you actually
have some kind of relationship with them
already
you can't just arbitrarily so oh the the
bottom line is there are lots of
different reasons why the the automated
crawler would fail harmonies are
ineligible case it would be ineligible
case yes
so in the end we were able to
successfully register on 2,300 sites
which was less than we thought we were
going to be able to do going into the
project but still sort of is a
reasonably sized number and then if you
would study this over a period of time
would you start to see that it's getting
harder or easier
I would hope harder to create such
accounts like it's harder so the number
of 23 is like for example have you
started to study again for another two
years it should come down to it which is
a good thing it is a good thing but at
the same time if we invested more effort
in our crawler then we could sort of
take take no account and deal with more
sophisticated ways of registering
accounts so I think I think we could
still sort of maintain it I guess my
point was so I'm sort of thinking like a
long time back you might remember when
we were sort of thinking about Wi-Fi
right things where everything was
accessible but then everything here will
default passwords became difficult then
everything was you know so eventually
like it kept going down and so then
compromising it became harder and so
there was a lot of papers written in the
past saying hey you can connected you
can do all this like thing but now now
it's not even I don't think this is
gonna go away because the sort of the
counterbalance is is that sites in
general don't wanna make it too hard for
people to register accounts and
particularly if you're not a top site
you so you don't want to make it hard
and push people away because you want to
attract people so that's why I think
it's going to balance out okay
the end result of doing the moderate is
that we did we detected 19 side breaches
which is almost 1% of the sites that we
were monitoring which is actually more
than I thought we were going to detect
okay so now I'll talk a little bit about
sort of characteristics of the sites
that that we did detect the breaches at
so these are tables we just letter the
the sites 8
yes the check mark and the hard column
means that the honeypot account that we
had associated with the site the
attacker was able to login using the
hard password so that man you know bad
bad practices on the site this is the
the Alexa ranking sort of modulo 500 and
then sort of the the category of the the
style of site that we see one nice
little bit of validation was it so for
all of these sites they had not been
confirmed who ever have been compromised
except for Bitcoin talk org they went
public about being compromised and we
had already had a honeypot account and
we were able to confirm that exactly
when they said they were compromised
sure enough you know the next day
somebody logged into our email account
and you know they are very clear about
sort of what their practices were in
managing accounts and they did a good
job in keeping passwords encrypted and
so we did not see a login to our hard
account hard password account the
question right here is that due to
methodological issues we only registered
an easy password account on that site
we did not register our hard one that we
did not we only discovered that
afterwards and so we don't know that's
why I had leave it a question mark so
when you've a check that means the hard
one was logged in each the cases where
the hard password was trying was the
easy one also tried on in general yes
both were tried not always but in
general yes so what why well why would
one knock the other if it's yeah if
they're going through all of the
accounts sort of systematically why
wouldn't they do it all of them I don't
have a good answer for that I think
there was one situation one of the sites
where the EZ account was not logged into
so just a clarification so when when
there is a compromised using a Hart
password
you were able to verify that they
weren't just like doing brute-force
attacks on all hard paths or they were
just doing one login attempt with the
exact password these were not brute
forced but let the ones where there
isn't a heart checkmark they they tried
to brute worth like you could see the
brute force attack they were not doing
any were not brute forcing account
logins at the webmail provider what they
were doing is they would take the
password database offline and then they
would brute force that offline and then
they would just use what it is they
discovered as a single login attempt
successful there are any public
compromised that well them that you have
account and you didn't see the email
account was used ah so there were no
there were no sites that had declared
themselves as being compromised where we
had an account and did not see it so
there were no we didn't miss anything
there were no false negatives yeah we
didn't miss anything would you be
talking more about what about these
sites you know yeah yeah
and it's you know it's easy to imagine
it's sort of a random hobby site out
there doesn't have good security
practices and can be breached but for
the sites were in the Alexa top 500 in
their home country so even top sites
like the the first one top 500 Alexa
ranking billion dollar company and the
hard hard password account was accessed
and then for these two they wound up
being the same company totaling you know
comprising about 30 million users but
only only the easy password was accessed
there okay yes your hypothesis is that
it was it was just an online guessing
attack at the at the the site in
question right offline guessing until
they had figured out passwords and then
they would just use those passwords at
the webmail provider the weak password
for the for the weak password yes so
what what why wouldn't you assume that
it was an online just a you know a
guessing attack against the server and
there was no there was no compromise
other than like you could a week with
those passwords I see so the question is
for the sites that were compromised were
those sites brute-force externally no
the question is for the ones for the
sites where the weak the weak account
was what was taken are you are you
saying that it was are you suggesting
that it was compromised that that
account was compromised because somebody
guessed and the password was so easy
that it was guessable online or that
there was a breach of the server and
they go and they did not like so that
would be a possibility which is that the
account was so easy that they would just
go to the webmail provider and just use
guests very simply that they could just
login there are two reasons why we don't
think that was the case the first is is
that the webmail provider checked to see
if there was any sort of brute force
attempts on any of the accounts multiple
logins before it actually was successful
online attack at the at the site at the
site not that they would have had to
guess his randomly generated email
dress as well as we get some good that's
what I'm getting for this Romania so all
of our email addresses are private okay
and then we're and they're not super
discoverable now okay so they are
themselves strong strings yes yes
exactly
all right so this is this shows sort of
from a timeline perspective what the
login activity is across the different
sites so this is time on the x-axis the
different sites are each each a row
going across and then we have two dots
an open circle for easy orange for hard
and it just shows you over time what the
login activity across the different
sites were and then the number in
parentheses one on the right why is the
number of logins per site these are
emails yes yes so these are attackers
logging into our email accounts at the
webmail provider using one of the two
different to us so 715 is here first
yes and now when did he first set this
whole thing up 715 I think was three
months after we started so what do you
think happened for three months not
nothing
well we did have a well we did have a
gap in that in that period where it
could have been that their accounts had
been compromised and we even detected I
have no good explanation for but it's
you know this we sorted them by time
first account access and you do see that
you know there are gaps in of months
before we detect another another
compromised so it's gonna be in the
month timeframe started yeah and I want
to read too much in the tea leaves what
are they doing when they'll open up they
sending spam
so this I I thought this was going to be
an interesting part of the study which
is looking to see what the attackers did
with the accounts and then went there
being an uninteresting part of the study
there were a few where the automated
systems that the webmail providers to
shut down the accounts because they were
sending out spam but by and large they
would log in look around and it's not
too much and they're doing this multiple
times so I just don't know I think you
know even though we did not we did not
but it's clear that they were logging
and repeatedly perhaps to test to see
whether or not that password had been
changed and whether the inventory was
still live provider talk to you one yes
what could it be that they were just
checking the liveness up account so yes
they can sell it yes that's my aunt's
verified account that's the best
hypothesis I can think of for the
activity that we saw I thought we're
gonna be able to watch all this you know
crazy stuff going on with the account
Zia it wound up being totally
uninteresting what's special about it
yes so there are a couple where there's
just crazy stuff going on in terms the
accounts and the number of the number of
log of the time between logins is very
very short I don't know one hypothesis
is is that those credentials were given
to lots of different people and so you
just saw lots of different people trying
over time are they not unique email
accounts the numbers are the right are
the number of unique login successful
logins to the email accounts associated
with these sites because don't you
registered a lot of email accounts so is
it under this same income I'm the same
account so just to be very concrete for
a we saw we had two accounts and we saw
two logins ones are the easy one to the
heart and then we never saw logins again
and then
and which had you know 570 again we just
had two accounts but we saw 570 logins
to those accounts so the it's a good
question the value on registering more
would be greater confidence that the
attackers were just going through an
entire password database but the
flipside is is that we wanted to
minimize harm so to speak to the site's
under question because we didn't ask
them if we could register how many
accounts with them we were just doing
that and so minimizing resources and
impact on them for the work that we were
doing wanted us to let us to minimize
the number of accounts that we had so
first compromise around 616 mm-hm
and you didn't warn that their site and
they kept compromising till 270 okay so
what I said not quietly when it was that
we notified for some of the sites it
took us a little while to notify and the
reason why was that the webmail provider
was doing this for us as a favor and it
required somebody's time and are
mentioned to go in and actually collect
log data and send it to us and that only
happened on occasion so there was a
delay in sometimes between when we got
it and when we notify and things like
that but it it is also the case that for
some of the sites where you re
registered you know for all these sites
we registered new accounts to see if
there was subsequent compromises and in
some of the sites cases that didn't
happen
we we could not get information detailed
information about what they were doing
with the inbox and we had not we've not
salted the inbox with that much
information because the challenge is
because we had created I don't know two
hundred thousand accounts or something
like that and doing that at scale winds
up being very difficult we did create
realistic profiles for all the
individuals so he names addresses all of
that stuff was was all valid but the
inbox itself was I'm interesting some of
them did and there were a couple where
they were sending spam at such a rate
that automated systems for the webmail
provider just shut down the account even
without our intervention but by and
large there was very very little
activity out of the accounts I was
expecting much more but they were not
being not being used
okay so then once we had gathered this
information and then sort of rolling
over time when we discovered a site was
compromised we would notify the site and
we would look to try to find the
appropriate contact addresses we'd send
them email and wait for a response and
whenever we got a response and for large
sites we got an immediate response not
just from engineering but also from
legal and um we were immediately as
helpful as possible explaining what we
did what we found all this kind of stuff
but it led to some interesting
conversations which provide some insight
into some of these sites so I'll just go
through some examples so I do want to
preface this that you know there was a
part of me that was actually feeling
pretty bad when interacting with these
folks because we were telling them than
we had been they had been compromised
but we had no insight how or why they
were compromise all we could to do is
add attacked it's like uh you've been
owned good luck so it's it puts them in
a slightly awkward position um only a
third of the site's actually wound up
responding to us but all of the big
sites well the majority of the big sites
did in the end though even based upon
what we were able to tell them no sites
ever notified users and no sites forced
the password reset on the accounts of
their site so it was not enough to get
them to do anything and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in the
summary so no on your notifying them did
any of the signs inform you that it was
against the policy for you to even set
up such so um it could be that the
acceptable use policy at the site said
oh you cannot use an automated system to
register an account and then when we
notified them their response might be
hey what are you doing we told you you
know our acceptable use policy it says
you know suppose we doing that what are
you doing nobody went down there
not one of the is a if I I'm a big
company I really have to take your words
and saying all this counter was never
used the only store here yes I I could
be very well you say you somewhere I
think was leaked not from master why do
I should go tell the hundred million
users just because yeah so we'll talk
about the top company in a second okay
well it starts small so going into this
we fully expected that we would we would
find sites that were well down the
electro rankings that you know it's run
by you know an individual or small group
of people it's not as if they have the a
giant security team and sure you know
they would likely have lots of problems
and sure enough yes we did run in those
problems and sites that had those
problems in interacting with them Lena
they would promise fixes soon but never
took action and the bottom line is is
they're they're too busy fighting other
fires so this was a great anecdote from
one of the sites which was like look
when we started this site I used to have
such admins but they kept on telling me
that I couldn't do things so I fired
them all and that caused even more
problems from you know probably not
surprising that that this occurred for
the large sites they were very
responsive except for for one and you
know we heard from different parts of
the company both engineering and legal
and for the the very top site the very
big one we have multiple phone calls
with them with where their lawyer just
asked as a long series of questions and
the idea behind the questions the goal
behind the questions was to try to find
a weakness in our methodology such that
they could point to that as being the
explanation for the account compromise
not to the site being breached Joe is
fantastic
and handle that questioning like a pro
and they could not find a
the armor they still did not cooperate
that there was a compromise but when we
got the last question we would ask is
well then what is another explanation
for words we found given everything that
that we've discussed and they would
never answer the question so for this
outdoor site it was a site that wound up
being purchased guide some kind of small
companies gonna go rummaging around in
the dark web find stuff on pastebin and
then contact companies saying of good
evidence that you've been breached you
know as a way of kind of like trying to
sell their consultants oh yeah FYI
did did you did anyone kind of indicate
or hint that they might have had because
there's a sense that there might have
been other channels that yes would
feedback one of the sites knew they had
been breached because somebody posted to
their forum saying hey we breached and
we duplicated your entire site and the
alternate site is running over here in
case you want to come over and use us
maybe your stats is getting kind of a
little she's money you're not 19 but
it'll be interesting to see of those
that are breached assuming all of these
are what percent actually end up on kind
of scriptable places like pastebin as
opposed to I'm gonna use this for myself
and yeah but I questioned the efficacy
of those services because like for
example like Microsoft employees if you
sign up for the for the legal plan one
of the things that they offer is to tell
you if your email account has been
compromised and the way that they do
that is you enter your personal email
address in my case it's shredder
gmail.com and then I regularly get like
a person that I'm saying that we found a
website where there was your email
address and some password you have no
idea - correct and I questioned their
head busy also yeah and I would say the
lesson that we learned for the small
site is even if they are notified
whether it's from us or whether these
other channels it's high enough we're
not a priority to do something about it
they're dealing with other fires yeah
does this call have I being armed with a
P calm yes net
and that actually works quite well
because I generally use unique email
address for all these sites that I
register with and they tell me like when
I the LinkedIn one and the Adobe one and
all the ones that are known to be
compromised I've received a notification
through that so my question is have you
considered cross-referencing your known
hacked accounts with that database now
that's a good question we didn't do it
better be yeah very good thing to do
yeah it's a good point okay so for this
site the site was purchased by a
competiting a competing site and at the
top at the time the site was handed over
to the competitor that is when we saw
the account being accessed from the
original site and so who know you know
there might have been an insider thing
not necessarily an external site breach
who knows what was going on there and
then for the for the very top one you
know this billion dollar company 15
million users so we had we did have
extended conversations with them over
time after we had gone through this sort
of entire methodology and they they
couldn't find a flaw the next call that
we had with them is they said that they
had hired of a third party instant
response team to review everything and
review their internals and the third
party team found though no indication of
site compromised but this was a site
that at the time that our logins we
observed logins to our accounts other
users were complaining on Twitter that
their logins on the site were
compromised and there was even a story
in in a newspaper about it but the the
site denied the allegations that that
they were compromised so for this one
actually we had some some additional
external validation that actually it
wasn't just our accounts who they were
compromising this time okay
an interesting side effect of this was
that if particularly for this site I was
sort of waiting for something like this
sort of a legal document handed to us
and we did get a cease and desist order
but it wasn't from any of the sites that
we monitored it was from trip wire Inc
who were very angry with us for calling
our system trip wire it's just it's a
name
we're not commercializing it okay so the
technique works we did a pilot study
found you know roughly nineteen
compromised sites one percent of the
sites that we were looking at it
compromisers were happening at sites of
all different scales the small ones not
so surprising but actually they were
large ones that didn't have sort of the
the greatest practices and none of this
none of the sites did anything with
their users as a result of this and you
know there's there's strong incentives
not to state that your site has been
compromised and so you can imagine from
their perspective if they have been
compromised the risk the impact on stock
prices all this kind of stuff of
declaring that versus sort of a research
team coming in and saying look we have
no other explanation other than your
site has been compromised with no
additional information that they're
willing to take the risk to say that it
didn't happen
earlier when you talked about the
difference between hardened and easy
passwords the fact that somebody would
log into one of your hard password sites
you said that that indicated that the
server was potentially having bad
password practices but but is that
necessarily the case in other words when
some sites compromised depending on the
nature of the compromised I may be able
to just observe people logging in
admittedly your your particular email
account nobody would have logged in but
are you are you sure that it can't be
absolutely certain so let's say it's the
case that somebody's installs malware
it's at the at the other end the HTTPS
connections are actually able to see
that you know the authentication
happened in real time as an RPC whatever
that's potentially we were not logging
into our account so they probably
wouldn't see ours so it's hard to have
that be an explanation for our accounts
but that is very much a limitation with
this technique which is it gives us no
insight into the compromised itself so
the following question is would for for
sites that are interested in detecting
their own compromised would you
recommend this technique to them yes
absolutely
okay all right I clearly created way too
many sides but that's okay I'm gonna
transition a little bit and talking
about sort of work that we've been doing
looking at DNS in particular the
introduction of the new top-level
domains and this is work that our
student Tristan did as part of this
agitation there's sort of two different
stages of this work and I will talk a
little bit about that the first one
because I know already that I'm not
going to really go to the second one all
right so here's the idea we're where we
were coming from and starting this work
you know DNS is absolutely critical
infrastructure for the entire internet
how we name things on the internet but
DNS domain names a particular wind of
being also being very essential for many
different kinds of large-scale abuse and
attacks there's value in having domain
names particularly if they have
reputation so I mean a lot of the work
that we did we would look at domains and
the use of domains sort of in the
context of a particular attack but the
introduction they new TLDs
just completely changes the the DNS
landscape and and so we wanted to sort
of get a sense for how this change would
eventually impact abuse and attacks and
so we started by just looking at what
was going on with the the new TLDs all
right so as for some context back when
we were in graduate school you know you
had 70 of these and the country code
Quixote's now 1200 new generic Quixote's
that's a lot okay what's going on with
those new TLDs
are they being used for okay so you know
we wanted to see to what extent what
what impact these new teas are having on
DNS and are the the introduction the new
TLDs sort of serving the stated purpose
that they are introduced for are they
meeting unmet needs that the lack of
those two giladhiz have and our approach
to sort of doing this foundation was to
examine one utility in detail and then
all new tea
these that were registered by the end of
2014 so at the time of this study it was
500k of these and we just look at all
domains crawl their content so on and so
forth okay and then our ongoing work is
sort of looking at you know analyzing
DNS from a global perspective to look
for abuse and attacks and weird ways in
which DNS is being used okay so I will I
will focus on on this first one because
it is again a very interesting story
which is the xxx TLD all right it's an
unusual TLD in many ways and it has a
very storied history
it's a TLD specialized for adult contact
the registry that proposed it was ICM
registry and they sort of had a story
for what the value of the domain was and
all this kind of stuff
but there was lots of criticism all over
the place and actually even the adult
entertainment industry did not want that
xxx the hildie to be created okay so I
can for various reasons approved it in
2005 and then the governmental Advisory
Council part of ICANN wrote a report
saying this is a terrible idea don't do
it so I can said okay fine we won't do
it
so they rejected it and then ICM
registry filed a complaint they didn't
append a review boards upheld ICM
Richard he's complaining and so I can't
said okay I guess we have to do it after
all and then it became active in 2011
okay so there was a story for what I xxx
was for and it's it represents one of
these early new generic top-level
domains and so we wanted to see to what
was the impact of xxx so we would just
enumerate all the registered domains it
turns out that because of how xxx works
it requires some inference it's not just
sort of a numerating the zone file
although that's one of the steps crawl
the content and then based upon what it
is that we could discover about the
domain we tried to infer the
registration to intent of the domain in
xxx
what is why did that person that
individual register that domain then we
would also estimate the cause
and the revenue as a result of the
domain registrations to ICM registry how
much money is ICM registry making as a
result okay the registration process for
this why winds up being unusually
complicated there are these things is
started with this rollout period and so
I see him registry since it was a new
opening up new territory new name
territory it wanted to try to capitalize
on new names being available and so it
had a premium for people to register new
names so some of the one part of that
premium is for people who might want
domains and xxx at sunrise a and then
there are people who don't want to have
domains and xxx and so there was another
period where you could pay money so that
nobody else could grab that domain for
you so there's in this period Microsoft
could register Microsoft a xxx so that
nobody else could register maestra
Microsoft or xxx for obvious reasons
okay and then there's a whole set of
names that are protected so for example
all US presidents senators congressmen
blah blah blah all of their names are
protected can't register them and then
finally after all this auctioning all
this crazy stuff happening then they
open it up to sort of general
registrations okay and then these are
these are the prices for registering in
the domain alright so what we wanted to
do is we want to do enumerate all the
domains of xxx crawl them find out then
eventually try to infer the intent zone
file gives you all the domains that are
registered and resolving and then there
are a bunch of names that are hidden
they're not in the zone file they're
just hidden because they're reserved or
non resolving things like that and so we
would have to sort of infer counts and
guess at what these domains might be to
try to get a sense of that the numbers
there for the domains where we could
crawl them we downloaded both their web
content of course all of their DNS
records as well as who is records and
try to use this as a way for inferring
registration intent okay so this is what
happens if you go to Microsoft out xxx
you get this page that pops up that says
this is Maine has been reserved for
registration so Microsoft paid $200 in
Sunrise B so that nobody else could
register xxx Microsoft out reflects
including Microsoft so Microsoft cannot
use this domain all right it's and this
web page is served out of ICM registry
which is the registry that they don't
strip elects so the intent here is to
reserved names and essentially protect
you from from other people registering
it there's another way in which sites
organizations people can protect
themselves from other people registering
them and it's the category is called
registered non resolving so for example
if you look up UCSD Det xxx so we pay
money UCSD pays money dice iam registry
for UCSD that xxx to get a non-existent
domain so UCSD pays money on a yearly
basis to ICM registry so that if anybody
tries to look it up it says the domain
is non-existent and roughly speaking so
it's you can't enumerate these there's
no way to enumerate them because they're
not in a zone file or anything like that
and so you have to try to sort of guess
what their what their numbers are and
roughly speaking the amount in this
category at least in the first year is
roughly speaking the same amount in the
reserved category like Microsoft's case
and the intent here is clearly to be
defensive you don't want somebody else
registering it so you're willing to pay
money so that they can't and then there
are two other categories one is
speculative so these are people who are
registering domains because they believe
that they'll be able to sell it at a
higher price to somebody else who wants
it down the line so parking pages so
this is an example of a parking page of
the domain and xxx they're just it's up
there the domain has been registered it
resolves if you visit it in the browser
they just want to sell it to you so just
specular speculation and then the other
is is primary this is actual content and
I didn't show a sweet check
for obvious reasons okay so do do the
enumeration do the crawl look at
everything we know what the costs are
for each of all the registrations all
this kind of stuff and then we can just
multiply everything out okay you get a
table that looks like this so we have
these four categories of the intent for
which people were doing the
registrations the number of domains that
were in that category and then
multiplying by the cost the amount of
money the revenue that ICM register you
received
okay so impressively 24 million dizm
registry just in the initial period for
people defending their names
they are just minting money all right
and then if you look at the recurring
cost these are the yearly so the doing
the reserve and sort of the initial
registration where you paid $200 so that
nobody else could use it forever that's
just a one-time cost but the UCS DS case
where they're doing the registry read
registered non resolving UCSD is paying
$100 a year at ICM registry so that
nobody else can register that domain and
the recurring costs for the revenue that
is coming the ICM registry less than 10
percent of it is due to people who
actually have adult content in XXX so
it's just a scam it's just a big scam
all right so this xxx meet the unmet
needs absolutely not
huge scam whatever adult content is in
xxx or is out on the internet it's not
in xxx you have to go elsewhere if you
want to find it but a huge cost to
everybody else so clearly you know a
failure from the perspective of why it
is that we might introduce a new TLD
okay so then we did it for all new TLDs
that so I can't open up the process of
registering for new TLDs in the January
of 2012
anybody could go out there and register
no Tod we were really excited and we are
starting the process when we realized
that there's you know $200,000 cost for
doing it which is even too steep for us
but anybody can do it there
during categories it was very
controversial at the time the good is
that it opens up vast new namespaces
beyond just the crowded calm but of
course that might have traduced
confusion at cause result in legal
battles all this kind of stuff so lots
of debate about whether this was
actually a good idea so we wanted to
sort of see evaluate you know for all of
these new ones what is going on inside
of the new TLDs okay what I'm gonna do
so same methodology roughly speaking of
xxx except we can't go into as much
detail because we have 500 TL EES and
all of the hundreds of thousands of
domains that are registered in all of
them okay but I'll just sort of
summarize what the results were so do
the new GL these meet unmet needs well
clearly there's a demand for new TVs the
fact that we now have two 1200 new
generic TL these people were really
excited about registering utilities it
is expensive and we developed a sort of
a profit model for these for these new
TL these how many registrations do you
need over how much time before you come
profitable and actually it's not clear
that the majority are actually gonna be
profitable down the line so there's
other reasons why they're registering
these new TVs there was not a deluge of
sort of lawsuits or confusion over
domains spanning one Tod versus another
certainly there are some organizations
that are protecting themselves Microsoft
would be one of them you register a
Microsoft dot star and just do that um
customers are using them so in the top
TL DS hundreds of thousands of new
domains are being registered and we did
this machine learning analysis where we
ask the question is the content on the
site of the domain registered in a new
TLD related to the name of the new TLD
and when there is content interestingly
80% of time it was so for dot New York
New York related websites dot London
London related to websites so to that
extent actually it seemed to be working
out fine but if you sort of look at all
the registrations it is still the case
the defensive
dominates actual content so only 15% of
the the mains that we were able to crawl
had real content on them the other were
either defensive let's say redirects or
something like that or they were
speculative lots lots of parking out
there in the in the new T of these are
they're replicating content that's
already on the dot-com or something or
is genuinely new new new generally new
new new so we tried to take an account
for that if there was a redirect or if
it was similar to the dot-com version
then we'd say Daniel yeah if I paid
$200,000 so nutshell D will kind of
write it do I have
oh okay right yeah okay yeah so the
business model is that as a registry
you're gonna own a new TLD dot wait on
now you will engage in business
contracts with registrar's like Go Daddy
Go Daddy will sell domains in that wait
on and you get to set what the price is
GoDaddy will take a sliver of every
domain registration and then you get the
remainder I can also get a little bit
too
okay and then you know this is still
sort of the basis of ongoing work at
looking at various kinds of abuse but
being able to do it now that we have all
this infrastructure are being able to
crawl sort of DNS at scale of looking at
abuse in the Indiana's head scale did
you compare it against everything else
or did you compare against things with
the same name com so we compared it
against the same name com we also at the
time that we were crawling all of the
new domains that we're pairing in the
new TLDs we also crawled new
registrations in comm to sort of see you
know what is the fraction of parked
pages in the new TLDs
relative to those new parked pages and
calm things like that and it was
absolutely the case that there was far
more defensive and speculation in the
new TLDs
for new registrations relative to who
calm relative to content there was more
new content was appearing in calm at the
same time that some content was
appearing in the new TVs and this these
percentages are for domains that
actually had a web server respond to an
HTTP request so there are lots of domain
registered domains in the new TLDs that
don't resolve or there's some kind of
error or there's a web error or
something like that this is just for
where we actually had content and can
look at it alright I'll stop there so
this is still you know an area in which
we're very active and working not just
sort of DNS abuse but sort of current
projects are looking at account
compromised by attackers you you pay an
attacker $100 you give them an email
address like Victor bought at Microsoft
comm and then they will give you the
password for a victor ball at
microsoft.com
yeah exactly add fried looking at
security outcomes OSN abuse phishing
looking at
you know VPNs are now being advertised
pretty pretty heavily it's like do VPNs
actually give you the guarantee that
they advertise to give you are they are
they storing stuff and resell you know
the interesting questions they're not
offering your VPN service we you know be
good for the privacy sensitive user who
doesn't want you know their online
activity to be viewed by a large
corporation Facebook only knows
everything about you so if you use them
as VPN I'm not gonna learn anything new
so I mean once you signed up came over
already
lateral phishing is I am able to fish an
account in a company and then based upon
that fish to count then go and
compromise other accounts or other other
servers so a it has become clear so if
you ever look at sort of the how
breaches happen in practice so if you
were to sort of let's say be go legal
consulted on a case where there are
reaches under under dispute um
the methodology actually is you just get
a toehold anywhere in the company and
then once you get that toehold then you
become very clever in trying to then
find the actual resources that you're
after
when you're compromising that that's a
and in fact it's the lateral step that
is that is very much under studied they
were trying to get a handle on use all
right so this is actually a a project we
just submitted to using a security last
week it's completely crazy I'm not an
online oh s a and user myself but so so
imagine you have an online social
network and there are various metrics
about your OSN account how many people
follow you how many people like you all
this kind of stuff okay there are
services out there that you pay them and
they will increase those metrics and
we're talking
and the in these services you know ah
you know let's say they're making a lot
of money from doing this a lot a lot of
money business and so I have my six men
how did you win it how bad it is
so the goal the project is to enroll in
the services using honeypot accounts
understand how it is that they work
based upon that understanding create
essentially signatures so you can
monitor at scale for the entire service
look at how the service operates at
scale look at how much money they're
making and then use that the knowledge
gained to intervene and shut them down
and in this case we actually looked at
different interventions over time to see
how services they react to different
interventions like there are services
that use these two like they're people
who use guest services and so learning
that these people have used that service
um we did not go down that path but that
would be another another way of getting
more information about the how the
service works yes it's just amazing that
the ecosystem that is built up around
this on metrics that don't actually mean
anything do you see you know this
password less authentication how do you
see that space you know they're going
forward with password still can here to
be the unfortunately yes you would say
yeah yeah I don't see passwords going
away anytime soon is that because the
other schemes are too expensive well it
comes back again to this this usability
question
nobody wants security users don't want
security sites want to throw on security
attackers don't want security
nobody wants security because it only
makes things more of a hassle and it's
this hassle slash convenience factor
about sort of two-factor authentication
and things like that that I would say
has has a limited the the adoption rate
of it
you know if your veer if you're a small
group creating Europe you know a site
for other people to use you just don't
that's not where you're trying to focus
all your time
now you can one way in which you can
sort of adopt it is that you can then
let Microsoft or Google or Facebook
authenticate for you but then those
companies get insight into your site as
well so there is a little bit of
trade-off going on there um but um
having the big sites authenticate for
you for seems like the the the greatest
hope for small sites adopting more
sophisticated authentication techniques
they're not going to do it themselves
but yeah passwords I still see them see
them here for for quite a while
all right well thank you very much I
really appreciate it
[Applause]